[Musique]
bonsoir en ce mois de mars qui célèbre
les luttes pour les droits des femmes
nous avons choisi de mettre en lumière
quelques femmes originaires de plusieurs
pays de la caraïbe qui ont dans leurs
domaines respectifs fait leur chemin
aux états unis elles sont écrivains
créatrice musicienne avocat ou femme
politique
vous les découvrirez dans un instant
dans le monde entier la quête des
vaccins anti cauri d une préoccupation
de tous les gouvernements pour les pays
pauvres c'est encore plus difficile
mais au delà de l'acquisition des doses
c'est l'organisation de la vaccination
qui peut poser problème dans un pays
comme haïti
habituellement le marché des médicaments
et très désorganisée
[Musique]
depuis l'élection présidentielle
américaine le monde a découvert dans
l'entourage du président byden des femme
noire d'origine caribéenne qui occupe
désormais des postes de haut niveau à la
maison blanche
elle s'appelle kamala harris karine
jean-pierre ou carey nombre et leur
parcours est clair celui d'autres femmes
noires américaines elles aussi
originaires de pays de la caraïbe et
donc de l'espoir à toutes les autres
coup de projecteur sur ces parcours de
femmes aux réussites diverses
c'est un reportage d'un jeune si médias
pour caraïbes aux états unis comme dans
beaucoup de pays développés la
participation des femmes dans le marché
du travail a fortement augmenté durant
les dernières décennies entre les années
50 et 60
les femmes qui travaillaient était le
plus souvent des femmes célibataires et
sans enfant
les années 70 et 80 ont vu l'arrivée
massive de femmes mariées avec ou sans
enfants mais il faudra encore attendre
deux longues années pour voir
l'émergence de femmes noires dans des
sphères économique et politique aux
etats unis
quelques décennies plus tard quelle est
la place des femmes noires dans la
société américaine d'aujourd'hui et plus
singulièrement des femmes d'origine
caribéenne
mais l'accession au plus haut niveau du
pouvoir de camara à risque femmes
politiques
originaire de la jamaïque devenue
vice-présidente des etats-unis a ouvert
des perspectives tout désormais semble
accessible pour une génération de femmes
talentueuses diplômés et volontariste
autre figure de référence désormais qu'à
rennes jean pierre d'origine haïtienne
né en martinique
elle a gravi les échelons pendant la
campagne aux côtés de kamala harris et
occupe depuis l'élection le poste de
porte parole de la maison blanche
ces deux femmes serait-elle le symbole
d'une nouvelle génération de femmes aux
origines plurielles prête à occuper leur
premier rôle dans la société américaine
elles sont jamaïcaine haïtienne
martiniquaise aux cubaines
elles sont avocates politicienne une
musicienne femme d'affaires artistes
intellectuels ou activistes
nous les avons rencontrés nous avons
mesuré leur ambition devenir une
référence
chacune dans leur domaine de compétence
c'est dans le quartier de little havana
que nous faisons notre première halte à
la rencontre de ces deux femmes qui ont
fui le régime castriste afin d'exporter
leur art aux états unis musicienne
d'exception viviane et yoanna nous font
vivre leur passion partagent leurs
ambitions parcours difficile semé
d'embûches car en floride
la musique cubaine est plutôt un domaine
masculin pour les femmes malheureusement
c'est toujours plus compliqué elle doit
faire face à de nombreux problèmes
en plus le marché de la musique latino
cubaine est généralement contrôlées par
des hommes à facile de progresser et de
se faire connaître
surtout en ce moment avec les problèmes
sanitaires et sociaux ce n'est pas
évident mais dieu merci nous nous
battons et obtenons des résultats grâce
à notre musique de type fusion cubaine
et caribéennes nous commençons à avoir
un public qui nous suit et qui nous
accepte en tant que femme et musicienne
nous travaillons croyons en nous et en
notre destin
[Musique]
c'est vrai les choses sont différentes
à cuba les gens sont plus habitués à
voir jouer des groupes 100% composée de
femmes ici c'est très différent sans
doute une question de mentalité c'est
nouveau pour le public mais même si ça
prend du temps nous achetons rien pour
voir leur nouvelle cote de popularité
auprès de l'un public
nous les avons retrouvés lors d'un
concert sur la calle ocho cette femme
cette musicienne de talent qui l'espace
d'une représentation oublie à leurs fans
les moments pénibles générés par la
pandémie du profit de 19
leur musique est 100% caribéenne
oh oui nous sommes caribéenne nous
sommes toutes cubaine et venant de
plusieurs endroits de l'île de la vanne
de santa clara de matanzas c'est pour ça
que notre musique est métis elle
s'inspire de nos origines diverses de
toutes les influences musicales que l'on
trouve à cuba mais aussi dans toutes les
autres îles de la caraïbe
c'est avec cette fusion musicales
caribéennes que nous voulons réussir
c'est important ces jeunes femmes
talentueuses et ambitieuses sont prêtes
à beaucoup travailler pour forcer leur
destin
comme d'autres avant m la référence
restant celia cruz quatre lettres k u
ltée pour définir le parcours atypique
de cette jeune martiniquaise de 37 ans
dont la voix semblait tout tracé
après des études à sciences po paris
jesse boon va là où personne ne l'attend
une expérience au mexique
la découverte d'une nouvelle culture des
souvenirs forts avec sa mère et sa
grand-mère des moments précieux qui
donne naissance à une ligne de bijoux
créés entre le mexique et maya me c'est
d'ailleurs à miami que nous retrouvons
cette jeune femme de 37 ans dans son
appartement situé à south beach où elle
reçoit une clientèle vip pour des ventes
privées
soyez la bienvenue nous allons pouvoir
travailler en détail sur votre nouveau
projet ça va être passionnant
je vous en prie entrée et prenez place
il ya l'histoire très émotionnel en fait
mon rapport aux bijoux a été très
déterminés par les expériences que j'ai
eu un enfant avec ma mère je me souviens
pas parmi les souvenirs d'enfance et ma
soeur ma mère qu'elle ouvre sa boîte de
bijoux calmement des bijoux par exemple
de ma grand mère de mon arrière grand
mère qui est telle que je n'ai pas connu
et je ne raconte l'histoire de chacun
des bijoux donc pour moi il y joue
c'était quelque chose vraiment de ses
trésors
c'est un moment particulier des changes
avec la mer c'était en apprendre plus
sur ma famille c'était prendre
conscience qu'en fait chaque objet a une
histoire
l'élégance antillaise l'esthétique la
force de caractère
le métissage et l'ouverture au monde
semble être pour jesse les piliers
fondateurs du succès qu'elle envisage
pour elle même mais aussi pour toutes
celles qui se battent pour un projet qui
changera leur vie et les caraïbes et en
général d'abord on a peut-être cette
faculté d'être plus facilement à l'aide
un peu partout parce qu'on connaît la
diversité on a grandi avec sa dalle hier
c'était fait partie de notre des vins de
notre vie quotidienne en fait
en grandissant aux antilles par exemple
tu vas à l'école j'ai aussi bien en
contact avec en fin de rencontre avec
tous les niveaux sociaux
tu en contact avec toutes les couleurs
qui existe déjà en contact avec toutes
les religions donc les les territoires
peuvent être petit mais la diversité est
énorme en fait et tu apprends à vivre
avec ça et ça c'est c'est pour moi je
crois que c'est bien des plus beau
cadeau qu'on a parce que quand tu pas
après quand tu continues vie ailleurs
compte quand tu t'ouvres au monde en
fait c'est un avantage de pouvoir parler
à tout le monde de pouvoir comprendre
les autres d'avoir cette capacité
d'avoir cette empathie et de ne pas te
braqué en fait de faire les choses
l'avancé quelle que soit la personne qui
est en face de toi ami pour ma part je
vois l'affluence des caraïbes plus
particulièrement des influences venant
des caraïbes françaises dans les
créations de jesse ces pièces sont
modernes mais ne sont pas ligne rl100
fait de courbes ce qui donne le la
sensualité aux bijoux
[Musique]
oui
donc là en fait on est à d'armes tarn
donc c'est vraiment le centre de la
ville de miami c'est une somme que les
gens ne connaissent pas forcément et on
va au centre des bijoux donc toute la
zone qui est autour du symbole building
qui en fait la nébuleuse
du monde des bijoux aux couleurs ont 10
heures la plupart des ateliers et des
caisses
[Musique]
geci a une façon bien particulière de
travailler chaque pays où chaque pièce
est pour ainsi dire unique quelle que
soit la pierre le diamant le rubis ou
encore le saphir tout est un jeu de
proportion de contraste à jeu de
couleurs entre l'or et les différents
métaux et je crois sincèrement que le
fait que j'ai 6 soit une femme
caribéenne rajoute un plus bas à chacun
de ses croquis et de ses créations
[Musique]
notre 3ème en compte nous conduit à
little haïti un des quartiers
historiques de la ville de miami
c'est le lieu de rencontres culturelles
et sociales qui réduisent nos petits cas
nous a donné rendez vous pour une brève
rencontre
cette écrivaine américaine d'origine
haïtienne né en 1969 à port au prince
sous la dictature des duvalier nous
décrit l'importance de la femme dans la
cellule familiale dans la société
caribéenne des femmes fortes et
ambitieuse mais qui selon elles restent
encore trop peu présente dans les
organes politiques et économiques de nos
régions
vous savez une en mer sont souvent au
coeur de nos histoires ou de nos récits
de nos vies surtout en haïti où la
dictature et la répression nous ont
enlevé kt en dom les poussant hors de
nos villes et jetant en prison ou les
poussant à l'exil
à cause de cela les femmes ont vraiment
dû prendre une place centrale au sein de
la société
bien souvent pour élever non seulement
leurs enfants mais parfois les enfants
des autres membres de la famille qui
font face à de grosses difficultés
les femmes de notre société qu'on
presque tous et sang partout elle vante
dans la rue pour certaines d'autres sont
infirmières professeur el s'instruisent
elles sont présentes mais en même temps
elles n'ont pas ou peu de pouvoir dans
la société
rares sont celles qui sont présidentes
de leur pays elles ne font pas partie de
la classe de dirigeants visibles elles
sont rares dans le gouvernement alors
que leur présence est notable dans nos
sociétés
quel avenir pour ces femmes
arrivé aux etats-unis il ya parfois plus
d'une cinquantaine d'années quel combat
doivent être encore menées pour les
générations futures
pour réduire une antique à la réussite
de certaines ne doit en aucun cas
occulter toutes celles qui vivent encore
dans une grande précarité
mais quand nous parlons de l'avenir les
femmes caribéennes
de quelle femme parlons nous car il ya
encore beaucoup de femmes dans nos
communautés qui même si elles vivent ici
aux etats unis sont encore très pauvre
nombreux sont celles qui n'ont pas
toujours accès aux choses essentielles
et vitales l'éducation le travail la
santé
elles souffrent et sont parfois
délaissés par leur conjoint et puis nous
avons dans le même temps des femmes qui
dans cette même communauté
une partie de l'élite elle sans médecins
avocates certaines dirigent des
entreprises d'autres réussissent en
politique
finalement l'avenir dépendra de la
femmes caribéennes et dépendra de
l'unité de la cohésion et savoir si
celles qui ont réussi aideront les
autres à progresser tout en accrochant
de meilleures opportunités pour elle et
pour les autres
[Musique]
arrivé en 1969 au canada après avoir fui
haïti avec sa famille parra juste débute
sa carrière artistique à 19 ans sur les
bancs de l'institut gérardin très vite
elle devient la militante
la chanteuse engagée que l'on connaît
défendre les plus faibles face à
l'adversité a toujours été son moteur et
elle a réussi à transmettre la
combativité à ses enfants
je me vois comme une femme qui serait
toujours à la défense les autres
sociétés aubry mais ou bien qu'ils
étaient en train d'être abusés il ne
mange pas ça sur la terre du ne manquent
pas ça dans la vie donc eh oui
laisser le pays sans le vouloir à cause
de la dictature des duvalier ça joue un
grand rôle
demandez aujourd'hui mais je vais vous
avouer que la dictature dictature des
duvalier au pad l'aube et la raison pour
laquelle nous avons laissé haïti sans
savoir quand pendant près de 30 ans par
un juste écrire des chansons politiques
engagées défendons le droit des haïtiens
chez eux mais également dans le sud de
la floride
ces paroles révèle l'amour de son pays
mais il ya une profonde douleur due aux
décennies de corruption politique et ont
transformé l'ancienne perle des antilles
en le pays le plus pauvre de
l'hémisphère occidental
cette ferveur l'activiste en ciel léguer
à sa fille aînée car entre dès son plus
jeune âge elle m'accompagne toujours je
n'avais nulle part où on a laissé
il était toujours avec moi et elle
comprenait tout ce qui se passait et à
la maison quand on parlait la dictature
des duvalier à chaque fois qu'il ya un
changement en haïti on a discuté
elle écoutait tous à la grande île femme
de conviction à l'image de sa mère karen
andré est tombé dans la bataille pour
les droits de l'homme dès son plus jeune
âge avocate et femme politique au sein
du parti démocrate
elle a accompagné barack obama lors de
ces deux campagnes présidentielle et en
2020 elle participe à la campagne
victorieuse de joe biden et de kamala
harris
aujourd'hui elle occupe le poste très
convoité de conseiller personnel du
président byden à la maison blanche
une sacrée victoire pour 7 caribéenne ma
mère est un phénomène elle est née en
haïti
elle a connu des débuts très modeste
ensuite elle et sa famille ont fui la
dictature en venant aux états unis à la
recherche d'une vie meilleure
très vite elle a débuté sa carrière de
chanteuse reconnue dans la communauté
mais aussi en haïti
sa beauté aurait pu l'aider à faire
carrière mais elle a choisi d'utiliser
son talent et son art pour la lutte
contre le pouvoir
elle est devenue une chanteuse elle a
utilisé ses talents d'artiste pour
soulever les questions de l'inégalité de
l'oppression politique en haïti pendant
le régime des duvalier
c'était courageux de sa part voir braves
est unique elle aurait pu être tué
surtout en haïti dans les années 70
karen andré fait partie aujourd'hui des
satellites de femmes noires qui imposent
leur vision de la société leurs talents
et leurs compétences dans un monde qui
ne l'auraient pas spontanément favorable
lorsque vous décidez de travailler dans
les domaines dans lequel j'évolue
actuellement vous devez vous préparer à
faire face à des embûches de taille que
sont le racisme et le sexisme
ce n'est pas normal mais c'est une
réalité
je travaille dans deux sphères
juridiques et gouvernementales
les deux sont majoritairement dominée
par les hommes mais la bonne chose me
concernant c'est que mes racines
viennent d'une femme caribéenne est une
femme forte ici d'une famille forte et
unie donc même si je suis dans un
domaine dominé par les hommes
je ne me suis jamais sentie intimidée
parce que notre travail nécessite d'être
forte sur le plan intellectuel pour que
nous puissions excellent
certes je ne pourrait sans doute pas à
lutter sur le plan de la force physique
mais sur le reste je suis une battante
et je ne crains personne
en fait nous les femmes caribéennes
nous sommes brillant si nous sommes
talentueuse nous sommes de rôle nous les
femmes noires pouvons comme toutes les
femmes être à la pointe de tous
[Musique]
et
c'est à sunrise dans une villa louée
pour une séance photo que nous avons
trouvé notre dernier portrait qu'a libé
thomson est une jeune femme originaire
de la jamaïque pleine de vie et d'audace
et surtout une travailleuse acharnée
rien ne semble pouvoir stopper sa
progression dans le monde des affaires
productrice de programmes tv créatrice
du premier musée caribe en floride et
patronne du magazine island ont redit en
quelques années d'existence
ce jeune magazine a déjà consacré ses
premières pages à de grandes
personnalités caribéenne wycleaf jean
tania mari julian marley
kamala harris écart entre la nouvelle
conseillère du président byden à la
maison blanche
[Musique]
je suis une anomalie
je suis un acharné du travail je n'ai
pas de mari je n'ai pas d'enfant je suis
tout simplement marié on travaille voilà
ce qui me définit je pense pour
commencer je ne vais pas vous raconter
toute l'histoire de ma vie j'en serai le
synopsis je suis allé à l'école
architecture ensuite j'ai quitté l'école
je suis partie chantée avec beenie man
vous savez cette star du dancehall en
jamaïque puis avec cai mani marley
j'ai fait le tour du monde c'était
passionnant j'ai longtemps été dans la
musique
ensuite j'ai fini par produire des clips
vidéo finalement je suis tombée
amoureuse de la création de programmes
tv et rapidement je me suis retrouvé à
produire pour la chaîne nationale ps
l'émission de télévision appelées tel
style of eye lance une émission sur le
voyage et les merveilles culinaires dans
la communauté caribéenne finalement
concept a évolué et donner naissance à
un festival ici à miami
à partir de là tout s'enchaîne et je
lance le magazine islands origins
magazine qui a reçu récemment le prix du
meilleur magazine de loupe le rite
décerné par l'association des magazines
de floride je crois sincèrement que
quand vous faites les choses bien les
gens apprécient et attentes de voeux que
vous leur proposer de nouveaux projets
de nouveau challenge et finalement il en
oublie même que vous êtes une femme
noire
[Musique]
adam
quand vous faites les choses avec un
budget restreint voire sans rien dans
les poches
c'est difficile de créer son entreprise
croyez moi ça n'a pas été tous les jours
facile excusez-moi j'ai tout sacrifié
pour y parvenir
parfois il m'arrive est de ne pas savoir
où et comment j'allais avoir mon
prochain repas j'ai fait des sacrifices
des choix de vie de carrière ce fut une
semaine difficile mais projet se sont
réalisées j'ai mis tout mon à mon sens
ma sueur et mes larmes
j'ai dû vendre ma voiture de l'époque
pour financer mon premier projet de
production télé pour effectuer mes
démarches je marchais et parfois gl à
vélo il m'est arrivé parfois d'emprunter
aussi une voiture à des amis si cela
était nécessaire
les choses s'enchaînent aujourd'hui pour
le meilleur mais le début de l'aventuré
a été un parcours semé d'embûches et de
refus rempli de petits et grands
sacrifices
mon parcours logan des satisfactions
mais j'ai connu c'est vrai des moments
de découragement de doute
j'ai dû surmonter de pénible épreuve
comme le racisme le sexisme de vous
entendre dire que vous ne réussirez pas
parce que vous êtes une femme et que
votre couleur de peau est trop foncée ça
fait mal mais je vous assure il ne faut
jamais baisser les bras
il faut continuer à avancer et se battre
je ne sois pas retenir tous les épisodes
triste et malheureux qui ont marqué mon
parcours
car rien ne va toucher ou une va entamer
ma résilience et détermination de
réussir
[Musique]
toutes ces femmes ont remporté des
victoires les maintenant au plus haut et
pour certaines jusqu'au sommet de la
diplomatie internationale
ces nouveaux visages de l'administration
byden donne de l'espoir à celle qui
doute qui commence tout juste à se
projeter dans un futur jusqu alors
improbable quand on est issu de
l'immigration caribéenne mais le chemin
est encore long est la réussite
éclatante de quelques-unes ne peut pas
masquer les difficultés de toutes les
autres le plafond de verre est peut-être
ébréché mais il résiste encore
[Musique]
l'accès au vaccin contre le virus du coc
vide est un enjeu majeur pour tous les
pays notamment les plus pauvres
le vaccin devient un élément de
diplomatie pour les grandes puissances
qui offre des doses aux pays défavorisés
comme haïti mais le plus compliqué sera
sans doute l'organisation de cette
vaccination dans un pays où les
médicaments les plus courants sont quasi
inaccessible pour une grande partie de
la population je vous propose de revoir
ce reportage tourné en 2018 par michel
gendre et william zebina sur le marché
du médicament en haïti
[Musique]
chaque personnage est un bon passeur
ça manque de réflexion voici que la zone
même au niveau des cas de choléra servi
dans le bus qui relie pétionville à port
au prince ce démarcheur vante les
mérites de ce qu'il prétend est un super
antibiotiques
il n'a jamais fréquenté les bancs d'une
école de médecine ou de pharmacie mais
il a du bagout pour bluffer les
passagers les convaincre d'acheter son
traitement soit deux pilules d'un
médicament soit disant bon pour tous
les cas traités pour passer 30 à 35
réfection la vexer je me barre de
recherche d'après fluconazole way de
madame au sexe au niveau de la ligue
nabil al masaood jusqu'à crois que ce
sera grâce à google
le démarcheur sait s'y prendre et les
voyageurs n'hésite pas à mettre la main
à la poche
selon m
cette activité légale est devenue
quotidienne rares sont les autobus
aujourd'hui ou ne sévissent ces vendeurs
ambulants autoproclamé à jean marchetti
mais dans un pays en pleine
déliquescence et où la moitié de la
population n'a pas accès aux soins de
santé de base
le champ libre et laisser aux marchands
médicaments tout genre ils sont partout
dans la rue comme derrière les portes de
pseudo officines ceux qui vendent des
pilules comme de vulgaires marchandises
la médecine naturelle ni traditionnel
est aussi de la partie
aux abords des marchés les oqtf
inventant des haut parleurs les effets
guérisseur de leurs potions des mixtures
douteuses war dangereuse fait de toutes
les feuilles dont dispose d'un fort
haïtienne les bombes ont fait des
grosses boîtes fellaghas acide gaz est
bon et quand cela ne suffit pas on
recourt ou d'opter grain si marchands
qui vendent des comprimés ou gélules à
l'unité
les haïtiens les appelle aussi pharmacie
à terre car avec leurs cuves est ou sacs
de médicaments il s'installe à même le
sol dans des endroits stratégiques pour
vendre leur assortiment de produits
exposés à longueur de journée au soleil
ou à la pluie la loi haïtienne interdit
la vente de médicaments par une personne
autre qu'un pharmacien
mais les vendeurs ambulants font leur
commerce en toute impunité les autorités
ferment les yeux sur ce marché parallèle
les vendeurs ambulants joue des carences
de la santé publique de la précarité de
l'ignorance de la population leur
clientèle est composée de petites
bourses
avid d'automédication baguette conquest
ne l'a plus calmes besoins et mon lit
j'ai pour elle n'a rien n'arrive à
silves au moins ça moche eh oui les
moins chères parce qu'elle l'oas et leur
pharmacien l'écouté bliss longue d'une
heure la qualité et l'origine des
médicaments écoulée dans la rue est
évidemment un certain beaucoup de
produits élaborés dans des laboratoires
clandestins traverse aisément la
frontière avec la république dominicaine
notre caméra n'étant pas la bienvenue
auprès de ses vendeurs ambulants nous
filmons distraitement nous faisant
passer pour des clients à la recherche
d'un médicament pour soigner un mal de
ventre
on nous propose d'emblée des
antibiotiques pour nous cherchons à
connaître la provenance
côté sorties à
si m
top
bon
[Musique]
tallec
notant d'heure nous propose de combiner
au traitement au deuxième antibiotiques
qui soi-disant lavelot sens
[Musique]
voilà sans prescription médicale j'ai pu
obtenir deux antibiotiques blanc appelé
amoxicilline et l'autre métronidazole à
l'origine a certainement sur la
plaquette est indiquée provenance de
l'inde l'autre le vendeur me dis que ça
vient d'eux d'haïti s'est fabriqué en
haïti en tout cas ces deux comprimés je
les ai vus pour 10 centimes 10 centimes
d'euro direction l'une des 200
pharmacies reconnus et autorisés du pays
nous voulons soumettre notre acquisition
professionnel qualifié
chaque année une liste officielle
d'officine et dévoilés par le ministère
de la santé pour le consommateur cette
licence affiché à l'entrée est
normalement gage de sérieux et de
garanties même si la plupart du temps
les pharmaciens sont absents dit comtois
on n'a aucun mal de vent voilà sont nos
athlètes de comprimés de son enfance
votre douleur abdominale la mauricie n'a
pas guérir la douleur abdominale
ça serait avec non avec un comprimé
amoxicilline avec une dose d'amorcer
civile va pas green douleurs abdominales
et déjà la douleur abdominale on connaît
pas lectio logis donc c'est évident ça
ne va pas guérir la douleur abdominale
et vous savez notre e-boutique le
problème là une dose d'antibiotiques
c'est un problème parce que maxime
outils qu'il faut prendre ça au moins
sur sept jours par mois si ça doit être
encore mieux la fois beau jeu sur sept
jours si tu prends une dose bye bye
avons un problème de résistance
normalement en jeu en pharmacie là c'est
en passant vient me demande encore plus
mais la mort du jeune d'origine on ne
sait pas possible vous allez faire un
traitement
voici déjà avec une dose de doses trois
doses la licence les installer le
problème va donner un peu plus grands
lacs simyo ticks à ça ça se vend pas
comme ça
ce médicament en vente libre ça doit
être pris dans les phares au cas par cas
on ne peut accepter aux données certains
antibiotiques mais normalement les
asymétries que ça devrait donner sur
inscription
qu'importe s'ils ne connaissent rien à
la médecine et aux médicaments
chaque vendeur de rue à sa technique
pour écouler ces antibiotiques ou
analgésiques
cet homme de 29 ans est dans le commerce
depuis trois ans c'est son gagne pain et
ils vont sans crainte ces médicaments il
est d'ailleurs le dirach avoir accepté
de témoigner
[Musique]
surtout ça avait dit le poissard l'on
lise thériault
le rookie salle bondée fish and beauty
monop de change donc aucune vérité ça
fait la moue flash des médicaments rené
toujours ici à au sae posologie en haïti
ou pas trop pourquoi l'amour ou bleu à
timothy officie ligne avant que ça un
niveau nous revenions way ou vanuatu
tout à point d eau
ce cocktail explosif de médicaments et
qui est nombre de professionnels comme
ce médecin spécialiste des maladies
infectieuses
aucun chiffre sur la mortalité liée à ce
phénomène n'est disponible
il n'y a pas de données officielles
comme il n'ya pas de pharmacovigilance
de laboratoires de contrôle de qualité
des médicaments en haïti
pour le docteur bernard auteur d'un
ouvrage sur le marché du médicament
le manque de volonté politique est
criant dans la lutte contre le commerce
informel
son regard aguerri et pourtant sans
appel les médicaments de la rue sont un
réel danger
c'est vrai mais santé publique on touche
surtout les antibiotiques et selon une
petite étude les médicaments les plus
vendus sont les antibiotiques les
analgésiques ça ça vaut les médicaments
anti-douleur ya vitamines on a aussi un
stimulant l'appétit qu'on appelle la cip
ou et nadine dont la vente a été
interdite pour les messieurs la santé
publique en 2003 2004
mais c'est parmi les médicaments les
plus vendus il ya aussi le fameux
misoprostol le cytotec que qui est en
vente dans tous les marchés et qui a
utilisé comme pilule abortive nova
question qu'on se pose d'où viennent ces
médicaments et certains ne vous disent
que c'est le médicament de la
contrebande
d'autres vous diront
des choses un petit peu plus aux
exemples et savoyen les agences donc les
principaux fournisseurs sont les agences
pharmaceutiques autorisée quoi qu'il en
soit je ne pense pas qu'ils alua pa
officielle pour essayer d'avoir une idée
de l'origine de la radio semaines ce
quart d'heure au bas de la ville tout
autour de cette pharmacie gravi tout un
monde parallèle nous sommes à deux pas
de l'imposant marché en fait au coeur du
plus grand marché de médicaments du pays
l'endroit est connu de tous
c'est illégal mais quasi tolère on vient
ici s'approvisionner en médicaments
comme on va au marché aux légumes une
véritable cour des miracles qui regorge
de produits issus de la contrebande ou
de la contrefaçon
le trafic sont bien rodés certains
détaillants comme ce vendeur sont dans
le business depuis une vingtaine
d'années
l'encore pharmacie oui oui bah j'espère
hambourg
[Musique]
la boîte va dire la boîte à 4,6 et l'a
achetée en gros
si dans cette zone à longueur de journée
plus encombré qu'ailleurs que nous
retrouvons jean philippe notre marchand
ambulant de médicaments il a accepté de
nous montrer l'endroit où ils
s'approvisionnent en produits quand il a
réuni suffisamment large sous baiser
angoisse l attaque machin avait été
toute ma chambre angoua en détail et la
machine en grosse galerie à dos ses
côtés des poids et voici l'entrepôt où
s'approvisionnent jean-philippe une
bâtisse tout en hauteur qui a résisté au
tremblement terre de 2010 comme aux
inspections de la direction de la
pharmacie
il nie officiellement que 48 des pots
distributeurs reconnus et autorisés dans
le pays
celui ci ne figure pas sur la liste
éditée par l'autorité régulatrice contre
les grilles une foule compacte se presse
quotidiennement pour acheter en gros
produits alimentaires comme médicament
un détaillant installé juste à côté nous
confirme que c'est bien un lieu
d'approvisionnement en caméra cachée
nous avons approché le patro afin de le
questionner sur son activité
le
nous avons sollicité depuis deux mois la
direction de la pharmacie et du
médicament n'a pas daigné répondre à nos
demandes d'entretien les portes du
ministère de la santé sont restées
fermées tout comme celle de la
délégation de l'organisation mondiale de
la santé
la question du médicament est
extrêmement sensible
selon cet importateur installé depuis
trente ans en haïti le commerce de rue
ne serait que la partie visible d'un
trafic juteux pour les milieux mafieux
chez nous malheureusement tout a été
fait pour que le médicament
se défasse entièrement de ses valeurs
thérapeutiques lui préférant uniquement
sa valeur vénale avec une forte dose de
spéculation là-dessus et je crois que
tout le problème du médicaments en haïti
vient de cette conception là les grands
labos à trop se retire actuellement le
pays
ça c'est dramatique d'affaires des
grands laboratoires se retire au profit
de la contrefaçon
en l'absence maintenant de rétorsion de
la part de la part des autorités des
trafiquants de gros trafiquants de tout
poil
ça constitue un terrain de prédilection
pour eux haïti compte trois fabricants
locaux de médicaments dans ce
laboratoire de production qui représente
5 à 8% du marché
on affirme respecter toutes les normes y
compris les bonnes pratiques de
distribution
nous venons quoi distributeur con
pharmacie autorisée par le ministère de
la santé dans ce laboratoire en
confectionne une soixantaine de
médicaments essentiellement sous forme
liquide comme cet anti anémique près de
2 millions de produits sortent chaque
année des chaînes de production
le fabricant affirme appliquer et
respecter les normes de l oms
en 1996 la négligence d'un fabricant
local avait causé la mort d'une centaine
d'enfants avec un sirop pour la toux
contaminé par un produit toxique la
profession aurait tiré les leçons de ce
drame
aujourd'hui chaque produit est contrôlé
vérifié numérotée afin d'assurer la
traçabilité
c'est la plupart de construction jason
ludique cet ep des thèmes généraux au
leurre puisque hui on le recommande le
point d'accepter un ennemi qu ils ont
pour laquelle nous avons décidé de faire
ce produit ne le vendrons déjà ça fait
25 ans et c'est le mauvais temps
une production locale qui est aussi
victime de la contrefaçon
le patron pharmacien de formation offert
la traque sans vraiment guère de
résultats face à l'inertie des autorités
il ya beaucoup d'objets contrefaits qui
n'entrent en haïti par la frontière et a
aussi des produits contrefaits
localement ce nom que nous les trouvons
nous les analysons et nos avertissements
le ministère oui oui c'est déjà arrivé
une ou deux fois ont averti le ministère
une certaine mollesse et des fois même
nous avons dit au ministère où se trouve
un est la source de la contrefaçon
donc nous attendons un peu le pouvoir
retranché aujourd'hui à la faculté de
médecine et de pharmacie de l'université
d'état d'haïti cette experte en
toxicologie à guerroyer contre la vente
dans les rues du temps où il était à la
tête de l'organisme de régulation de la
pharmacie entre 2003 et 2009 cela n'a
pas été facile il y aurait des hommes
puissants derrière cette pratique ce
noël pour s'attaquer au problème
il faut d'abord une volonté politique
volonté politique s'est vraiment fait à
cesser même si pas de manière de manière
mais attaquer le problème à parler est
une campagne former la population
on avait en 2005 je crois lancer la
campagne contre la vente des médicaments
des rues je sais quand même une épée de
damoclès sur la tête des indices et vous
consommez médicaments vous ne savez pas
ce que c'est il ya eu quand même des des
incidents majeurs
il y avait le problème avec les usa t
qui avait quand même su et des agences
et l'on a retrouvée dans certaines
pharmacies non reconnu
c'est ce qu'on appelle la contrefaçon
médicaments mais ma sphère mais en fait
c'est pas jusqu'à date
on n'a jamais su ce qu'ils étaient dans
le stade et vous voyez bien des
médicaments qui ont qui n'ont pas de
ressources que les agences ici certaines
agences
donc ça c'est un autre problème et lors
de la campagne
je me rappelle ali propre ministre avait
bien dit qu'il fallait pas vendre aux
marchands du à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
autorisé quand on a lancé la compa
gérable il ya eu des manifestations
parce que les vendeurs de médicaments se
satelliser et lors d'une enquête ils ont
dit c'est ce qu'il trouve à faire mais
c'est pas une justification c'est la
sainte et déjà trouver autre chose à la
rue nous voici celle aux 10 39
importateurs de produits pharmaceutiques
autorisés dans le pays
robert brisson dirige cette agence
d'importation et de distribution
ils s'approvisionnent directement auprès
de fabricants de médicaments locaux ou
étrangers
les produits sont entreposés chez le
grossiste est normalement vendus
uniquement aux pharmacies dépôts et
hôpitaux reconnu mais ça ce sont tous
des produits enregistrés au ministère la
sagesse adp bo dpm est monté la section
de la dgi ministère qui s'occupe
précisément de l'importation et de la
commercialisation distribution de
produits pharmaceutiques
il ya toutes sortes de médicaments
antibiotiques d un tissu 6d à diana
malary qu tout au tout la gamme
d'abord de l'aisne une partie de la
république dominicaine et comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure une passe et de
fournisseurs locaux michel lamarre
réguler le cul ou importateurs privés de
vaccins en haïti il fait partie du
syndicat professionnel que préside
robert brisson l'association des
importateurs et distributeurs de
produits pharmaceutiques
elle regroupe 18 des principaux
opérateurs privés représentent 70% du
marché
en haïti les importateurs sont
considérés comme ceux qui font la pluie
et le beau temps et prennent les plus
grosses marges des idées reçues selon le
président des importateurs qui
relativise aussi de l'anarchie qui règne
sur le marché
l'anarchie dont vous faites allusion
c'est peut-être elle appela possibilité
compte certaines personnes de faire un
peu de contrebande
avec les médicaments en passant par la
frontière ouais mais normalement notre
association fonctionne selon des règles
bien précises et bien déterminé par
l'état haïtien
oui donc il n'y a pas vraiment
l'anarchie
c'est le mot est fort il ya peut-être
des dérèglements qui peuvent arriver au
coût de la commercialisation de certains
produits mais mais en fait il ya pas
vraiment d'arracher une des conditions
pour faire partie de l'association des
importateurs et que vous soyez un règle
avec l'état avec l'état avait dû être
avec vous même d'abord obtenir vos
autorisation de fonctionnement en tant
qu'agence ensuite que vous conformer aux
règlements de l'état haïtien qui vous
demandent bien spécifiquement de
nouvelles confirmations et au dépôt
autorisée par le ministère
selon les derniers chiffres que nous
avons à l'heure actuelle il ya 200
pharmaciens en haïti la moitié de ces
pharmaciens la travaillent dans des ong
donc il n'y a pas suffisamment de si on
fait le calcul rapide
il n'y a pas suffisamment de pharmaciens
pour travailler dans les 200 ou 250
pharmacie autorisée et on sait aussi
qu'il y a peut-être un millier peut-être
de pharmacie non autorisées qui ont on
ne parle même pas de mes deux vendeurs
dans les rues on parle de rêve de
pharmacie quand des enseignes de
pharmacie mais qui ne sont pas autorisés
par le mystère la santé donc le décompte
est facile à faire donc c'est pour ça
que au niveau de notre association on en
a parlé on a simplement suggéré que
peut-être y aurait peut-être certains
forment certains produits qui sont des
hôtes essai qui pourrait être de vendre
de façon officielle
non pas dans les pharmacies officiel
mais vendus dans d'autres structures
simplement pour permettre à la
population dans son ensemble d'avoir
d'avoir plus facilement accès à des
produits qui viendrait se disent on
d'une source autorisée
plutôt évidemment avoir à faire des
médicaments qui sortent d'une source non
autorisée dans les rues ces trucs qui
loge l'hôpital général actuellement en
reconstruction est connue de tous les
port au princiens si la rue des
pharmacies il y en a en abondance et bon
nombre sont hors la loi
même la distance réglementaire de 300
mètres exigé entre deux pharmacies n'est
pas respectée il y en a besoin de faire
masser sur la haute là derrière noir
côté de moi y'a le bonnes pharmacies ya
ya de bonnes pharmacies mais il faut
savoir choisir tout ce qui est appelé
pharmacie en haïti n'est pas forcément
pharmacie pour séparer le bon grain de
l'ivraie
nous nous référons à la liste des
pharmacies autorisée publiée chaque
année par les autorités sanitaires
évidemment ici peu d'officine y figurent
d'ailleurs quand on s'enfonce dans les
corridors les pseudos pharmacie
ressemblent plus à des cabanes de
médicaments elles sont nombreux et c'est
dans leur local grands comme cagibi
règne une chaleur étouffante des
conditions d'hygiène et de stockage
évidemment déplorable pour la
conservation des médicaments j'avais
initié cette histoire de liste de
pharmacie autorisée vous pouvez pas
d'une décision une année vous réfléchi
ce nom ne tient pas la route
est ce que quelqu'un haïtien doit se
soucier de quelle forme ainsi sont
autorisés à fonctionner je vais dans une
pharmacie
si elle n'est pas autorisée vous la
fermer s'il m'arrive quelque chose c'est
l'état qui est responsable
dont un certain moment l'état doit avoir
le courage de faire vous ne vous
fonctionnez dans l'illégalité fermer
votre porte
peut-on se procurait tout ce que l'on
veut dans ses boutiques de médicaments
ces pseudos pharmacie avec une fausse
ordonnance de morphine nous allons voir
si nous obtenons ce médicament classé au
tableau des narcotiques des stupéfiants
la délivrance de la morphine ce dérivé
d'opium et comme partout ailleurs
réglementée et soumis et extrêmement
surveillée au point d'ailleurs que
nombre de pharmacies autorisé légalement
possède même pas dans leurs officiers
ordonnance en main notre chauffeur se
présente dans une des boutiques qui
opèrent illégalement la morphine est
disponible placé sur les étagères à côté
d'autres médicaments sans plus de
précaution
côté tarifs ses 1700 gourde un peu plus
de 20 euros plus surprenant la boîte que
nous présente la vendeuse et en
néerlandais indique que les comprimés de
sulfate de morphine sont dosés à 30 mg
soit six fois plus que la dose prescrite
sur l'auteur de nantes les médicaments
sont pas des moments les médicaments se
sont pas des surette ce balayage et le
ghana et
et les musulmans sont dangereux de a à z
de l'aspirine jusqu'aux hinault vu dinh
c'est dangereux et
maintenant on peut pas vendre les
médicaments comme des patates l'autre ça
c'est mon problème c'est un tueur
silencieux
c'est un tueur silencieux on ne sait pas
combien de personnes montent à partir de
la prise de ce médicament là n'importe
qui ou une pharmacie
et quand vous allez dans la pharmacie
vous n'avez pas de forme assez pour vous
conseiller pour quand j'en suis étudiant
je lui ai dit c'est le seul complexe que
j je n'irai pas là où je te dise
officines où l'on peut trouver
l'assistance de pharmaciens et de bonnes
conditions de conservation des
médicaments cela existe à port au prince
celle ci si tu as tellement est
considéré comme un modèle une référence
bien sûr pas à la portée de toutes les
bourses en haïti chaque pharmacie fixe
le prix de ces médicaments
l'accessibilité financière reste un
problème majeur
en l'absence de contrôle de régulation
et surtout de volonté des pouvoirs
publics
les petits débrouillards des rues hante
encore de beaux jours pour leur activité
aussi lucrative que dangereux merci
votre attention à très bientôt pour de
nouveaux reportages caraïbes
bonsoir
[Musique]